Aquí tenemos dos números: en el número de arriba
tenemos 1, 2, 3 decenas, y tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 unidades, 3 decenas y 5 unidades o 35; el
segundo número tiene 2 decenas: 1, 2, y tenemos 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 unidades, 2 decenas y 7 unidades.
Ahora, lo que queremos hacer es sumar estos
números, queremos sumar 35 + 27, u otra forma
de pensarlo es que queremos sumar estos bloques,
queremos sumar todos estos bloques, así que
comencemos en la posición de las unidades.
Aquí tenemos 5 unidades y aquí tenemos 7 unidades,
de modo que si sumamos 5 unidades más 7 unidades,
¿cuál va a ser el resultado? Vamos a tener 12
unidades, vamos a tener 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11 y 12. Ahora podría notar un problema
aquí, que si sumo 5 + 7 no podemos escribir el número 12
utilizando solamente la posición de las unidades,
sólo podemos tener un dígito, no podemos tener
dos dígitos aquí. Entonces, ¿qué podemos hacer?
Bueno, lo que podríamos hacer es tomar 10 de estos
bloques y agruparlos como 1 decena y ponerlos
en la posición de las decenas. ¿De qué estoy
hablando? Bueno, lo que podemos hacer es tomar 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 y 10, podemos tomar estos
10 y agruparlos en una de estas barras, así que
hagámoslo. Los agrupamos en una de estas barras
y luego ponemos esta barra en la posición de las
decenas, entonces lo que estamos haciendo aquí es
tomar estos 10 y reagruparlos en la posición de
las decenas. A veces a esto se le llama "llevar",
en lugar de escribir 10 unidades lo escribiremos
como 1 decena, entonces en lugar de escribirlo
como 10 lo escribiremos como 1 decena. Entonces,
¿qué significa esto? Bueno, ahora sólo tenemos
2 unidades en la posición de las unidades, sólo
tenemos 2 unidades en la posición de las unidades,
pero ahora tenemos 1 decena más en la posición
de las decenas, tenemos 1 decena más en la
posición de las decenas. A veces a esto se le
llama "llevar", porque decimos 5 + 7 es 12,
escribimos 2 en la posición de las unidades
y escribimos 1 en la posición de las decenas:
12 es 1, 2. Déjenme dejarlo muy claro: 5 + 7 =
12, y todo lo que hicimos fue escribir el 1 aquí,
lo escribimos en la posición de las decenas,
lo escribimos aquí arriba; por eso parece que
lo estamos llevando, lo estamos poniendo en un
lugar más alto, pero lo estamos escribiendo en
la posición de las decenas, y lo más sencillo es
ponerlo aquí arriba. Pero recordemos todo lo que
hicimos: lo que hicimos fue decir tenemos 5 + 7
que son 12, no podemos escribir un 12 en el lugar
de las unidades, entonces tomemos 10 de esos 12 y
reagrupémoslos como 1 decena y luego tenemos los
dos que quedan aquí. Pero una forma fácil de
pensarlo es 5 + 7 = 12, 1, 2, y ahora podemos
sumar en la posición de las decenas: tenemos
1 decena más 3 decenas más 2 decenas. Bueno,
¿cuál es el resultado de eso? Bueno, eso es
igual a 6 decenas: 1 + 3 + 2 = 6, así que
hagámoslo. Tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 decenas,
6 decenas, ¿y qué significa eso? 1 + 3 + 2
decenas es igual a 6 decenas. 35 + 27 = 62, 35
más 27 es igual a 6 decenas y 2 unidades, 62.